welcome to what's wrong with these
people tonight's star Mitt Romney roll
it
well as you all know today is National
Hot Dog Day and perhaps you also know
that hot dog is my favorite meat I love
Hot Dogs uh I love them in buns I love
them outside of buns I love them with
baked beans I just like hot dogs it's
the best you know meat there is without
question so to all of you who like me
are celebrating a national hat Hot Dog
Day uh congratulations to you and may
there be many many more hot dogs served
in our wonderful land
that that's his favorite meat
yes I felt like I was watching some dark
sexual secret like him out of his garage
he's like I like hot dogs in the bun
like an outside the bun I like rubbing
my hot dog against the pot oh God I I
like when my hot dog barks
I like ketchup for my hot dog
that was that was the creepiest hot dog
ever does this guy have friends did
anyone try to talk him out of this video
yeah
don't walk and talk Mitch that's the
first thing well I you know you said his
dog doesn't bark at least this dog
wasn't in a cage on top of his car right
yeah we're just tied to the wreck yeah
thank you for these people don't
remember this story I'm gonna berate
them individually yes what's the dog's
name his dog's name like see Miss Seamus
same Sheamus oh is it Sheamus I can't
remember all I know it was on top of the
car pooped everywhere he got in trouble
for that
cat I hear he has binders full of
wieners
did we do this story so we could make
that joke yes
people don't remember that he remember
binders full of women I do oh that's
good I thought the video was amazing
yeah because it made me laugh and I did
not think Mitt Romney could do that yeah
do you notice something cat the hallway
is very long no that that Trump was
right about how he walks like a penguin
did you I just noticed that now
oh that is interesting yeah do you think
he has a heel problem I apologize if he
has a medical condition penguinitis I
don't know but he just said when he
congratulated everybody for eating that
I lost it and then when he was like many
more hot dogs and what was called the
wonderful land I mean that's comedy yeah
it is pretty amazing you imagine that
maybe Anthony Weiner is somewhere
holding a mint
well
I thought the mayor
there's a mayor running against him who
said well if he hasn't worked so hard to
get Joe Biden elected that hot dog
wouldn't uh would have been half as much
so a little inflation humor that's right
which I think is liberated yes it's very
well we'll see if he runs why is it so
hard for him to be human I'm not sure
because he's a very nice guy he's
uncomfortable he's always feels
uncomfortable he's probably a very nice
person right a really good person but
you remember that like like but in any
kind of situation he has a problem he
had a good one debate with Obama that
was really good right and then he threw
the other one in the street he actually
was right about Russia remember yeah he
was he was right about Russia was he
what did he say they're our number one
uh geopolitical foe oh no and he said
he's 1980s called and they want their
foreign policy that he's wrong because
it's China well number two you're number
two Liz
I don't know from the business
standpoint you work at fpn that's our
sister Network thank you yes if you
don't have it
you don't have it
uh let's talk about the economics of hot
dogs really or no I'm kidding
I just wanted to give you a boring
question yeah that's really boring let's
talk about beef you know you like a good
hot dog man no Jim already perverted the
meat so I can't do it anymore I think
Mitt Romney perverted yeah okay let's
talk about that Liz the way he held the
hot dog was creepy I didn't even know
there was a wrong way to hold the hot
dog you hold the hot dog you kind of
like when you hold a hot dog you're
eating you're kind of just eating it and
you had ketchup on it which is kind of
strange yeah I know yeah but you know he
opens saying as you all know it's
national hot dog day I didn't know that
and then he's saying that as you all
know I like this is my favorite meat
there's not one thing that's meat in
that hot dog yeah
yeah who's he talking about yeah and
he's a sweet guy but this is such a
non-sequitur why did he decide to do
this you know what he did he wanted he
he he wanted to reveal a picture of a
wiener that doesn't belong to Hunter
Biden okay that's staying on staying on
the story it really is selfless
it's very selfless
I love a good hot dog I really do
they're amazing you know what I may be a
weirdo but I like a boiled hot dog with
ketchup no with mustard oh no and I
don't even cook the bun I just like a
soft bun I like to just shove it in my
mouth
no
up next scientists furiously race to
solve sex in space hey Sean Hannity here
hey click here to subscribe to Fox News
YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else